is this when you start kind of looking
at the forecast now they're saying six
eight ten inches of snow possibly
saturday night into sunday all that
stuff and kind of thinking about that i
don't know i mean we played snow games
here uh unexpected snow uh all cold
games so uh to us it really doesn't
matter we're ready to play whatever kind
of weather comes
so we feel like it's an advantage for us
packers running back aaron jones on the
possibility there will be snow now if it
doesn't snow on sunday and only on
saturday there won't be snow on the
field it's only an issue if it snows
during the game because they keep the
field covered yes and they got heaters
underneath it could be very interesting
for some folks in green bay they're
already extending the offer of 12 an
hour to show up and shovel snow because
they got to get it
out of the stands right and put it
somewhere so people can actually you
know sit down and watch the game but
they're looking at up to 10 inches of
snow saturday night what a shame that's
not the saturday night game i mean who
doesn't love a good snow globe game i
i'm with you it is it looks great on tv
now it doesn't always mean it's the best
football and i i actually think for this
one i don't want to see snow
on the field during the game because i
want to be able to see russell wilson
and aaron rodgers make magic and be able
to move around and do the things that
we've seen them do so often so uh
patrick mahomes can do it if he can do
it they should be able to well yeah they
probably could but i guess i'm just
saying it takes away a little bit of the
sexy factor of things like that that's
where i worry about it and it is a
distraction too because even though
they've made technological advancements
to help us all understand exactly where
the ball is it is harder to enjoy the
game and follow the game when
the snow has covered up all the numbers
and hash marks and lines on the on the
screen but that likely won't happen on
sunday they'll deal with it saturday
night
um let's focus on the running games
right we know aaron jones needs to have
a big game to balance out the passing
game and compliment aaron rodgers and
aaron jones at times this year has
played like an mvp candidate not enough
to be an mvp candidate but at times he
has right the seattle running game yeah
right you were a big proponent of
the seahawks having their passing game
taken away by the eagles and being
forced to show they can run
and you still feel that same way this
way i do definitely i mean hey listen
the running backs of the seahawks last
week it was 17 rushes for 19 yards
that's why when the game was going on in
the third and fourth quarter a few times
i was yelling at the tv going why do we
have nine guys at the line of scrimmage
like this is uh franco harris and the
pittsburgh steelers in the mid 70s i
don't i didn't understand it so if i am
mike pettin who not only has corners who
can play man but he plays a lot of
creative zones behind it i would err on
playing those creative zones and keeping
people deep i'm not gonna let dk metcalf
and tyler lock it go bombs away over the
top you know seattle thrives on the big
play they're really a team that's not
really known to go oh hey ten play drive
and oh bam five yards here eight yards
here five yards here 10 yards here
that's not what they do they're a little
bit just hey run for five run for four
you know get a first down whatever it
may be oh let's take a deep shot down
the field if you look at a lot of their
scoring drives they're always like five
play 75-yard drives things like that i
mean
right i would want to see can marshawn
really carry the load can that offensive
line really get it done green bay does
have a weak run defense but it's been
better late is is
is part of the effort by the eagles and
possibly by the packers to take away the
running game
avoiding being the victim of a
rejuvenated marshawn lynch i mean is it
just the threat of marshawn lynch having
a turn back the clock game is that
what's causing them to do it i don't
know no i think it's really an old
school coach and jim schwartz who always
wants to take away the run the seahawks
are famous for of course pete carroll
ball where he wants to run and dominate
the livestream yeah and you say run and
stop the run you're hired yeah well yeah
well you're right but but but the work
out but it might not work out but you
get you get hired yes no doubt about it
so yeah i think that's what jim schwartz
was thinking a little bit he was trying
to give some different looks that way
but yeah it came back to burnham and
bite him in the butt in the end and that
you know yes i am you know the packers
towards the end of the season they're
run defense i complained to about two
guys in the middle of like hey kenny
clark the two smiths preston and
zadarius are phenomenal the other two
guys on that line lowry and lancaster
they were underwhelming for like the
first eight to ten games of the year but
they really came on towards the end and
their defense kind of tightened up in
the run game so i i if i'm them that
would give me pet at least if i'm mike
pettin the guts to go okay i'm gonna let
my front see if they can hang in there
against these big boys who are not
totally 100 in seattle's offensive line
and i'm gonna keep safeties deep and
savage deep and uh you know adrian amos
over the top of dk metcalf especially
early on and makes seattle have a hard
time finding some some continuity or
some explosive plays on the offensive
side of the ball and the seahawks are
expecting more from marshawn lynch she
had six carries seven yards against the
eagles and a touchdown
but he's been back long enough that he
could be closer to football shape this
weekend but also fresh legs
there's a sweet spot there where you've
done enough to get yourself back in
football shape but you're not as banged
up as everyone else because you haven't
played all year long right the question
is can the seahawks survive long enough
for lynch to get to that point and at
his age what is his match that's the big
question i think i think you're exact
that's where i would go you know okay
yes we're going gonna give him more but
like you know you gotta be careful i
think about how much more if we're gonna
go like 25 30 times well if you did that
i would bet he fumbles at some point
or something bad happens i i do you know
i don't think he's gonna be quite ready
to just carry the load like beast mode
2013 all over again i do think we'll see
more of them because of the weather and
things like that and you hear pete
carroll talking about it uh but uh i
still think that if seattle's gonna win
this game it will be with russell wilson
making magic as we've seen him do all
year seattle just wants to get this game
into the fourth quarter and have it a
one score game and they just believe
that their players will make plays and
pete carroll his energy and russell
wilson will come through that's really
how they played the whole year
and that's why i'm picking them and i
don't feel comfortable about that but i
picked them to win and i'm scared that
here's the thing if this game was being
played in seattle yeah i would firmly
believe the seahawks are going to win
right formally without question could be
wrong but at least i would believe it
lambeau field i have no idea yeah i
really have no idea because i think both
teams this year have had a little bit of
that as you would call horseshoe is it
horseshoe up the butter shamrock yeah we
gotta go with both i go with both maybe
one of each
rockets right and a shamrock and a
horseshoe you're really lucky if you get
them all up there but that's the full
house
but but really
both teams have that vibe yes because
you know i've been asked this question
all week long how in the hell did the
packers go thirteen and three it's
really the most underwhelming two seeds
i i feel like i've ever seen
i mean do you feel that way yes okay
they were they were two inches away from
a one seed if jacob hollister scores the
touchdown in week seven you're exactly
right yeah or or we're sitting there
watching them get dominated in the first
half of the lions game and aaron rodgers
being off and we're going oh my gosh
they're gonna you know they're gonna be
you know end up having a much tougher
route here as far as the playoffs
concerned but they rebounded played
tough and found another way to win a
close ugly type football game thursday
thursday was my my heavy psychoanalysis
day and you gave me a hard time right
for it but there's one lingering point
that i need to reiterate yeah i firmly
believe that the packers
likelihood of winning is going to hinge
on what happens i know you do saturday
yeah if the vikings win i think the
packers are far more likely to win
because they'll know they don't have to
come back here to san francisco where
they got stomped by the 49ers and if the
49ers win i think it swings to the
seahawks i really do
listen i think there's a lot to that no
doubt about it that could definitely
juice a team up when you see that the
night before the game in the hotel and
you're going oh my gosh we got a chance
to host the nfc championship game next
week against a team we beat twice to go
to the super bowl yes you know that
could be good it could be also it could
be bad because then your mind starts to
go to the future and you start to think
about that game and then i'll say
seahawks hit that edge too yeah they win
that game and the vikings have beaten
the 49ers they're going to host it but i
think for the 49ers the the pendulum
doesn't swing as far like they got no
problem coming back here and playing the
49ers it almost feels destined they're
going to play the 49ers again yeah so
what hey we host the game so what you
know what the way the vikings played
them late in the game maybe they'd
rather play the 49ers again because if
the vikings can continue what they did
late in the fourth quarter yeah it's
going to be a different outcome but i
think it's going to affect the packers
more i think mentally and i say that and
not this isn't just pulling something
out of the air four years ago
i met five years ago
when the colts beat the broncos
in denver in the division around
remember that game yeah sure and then
the colts went to new england and it was
for the fight yeah right damaris thomas
told me at the super bowl that he
knew there were guys in the locker room
for the broncos that didn't want to go
to new england the next week they didn't
want to go there
and at some point that's going to affect
your ability to to check the box to earn
a trip to a place you don't want to go
play yeah definitely yeah i mean you're
right i mean listen the part of being a
good team and a good athlete is being
mentally tough and not even letting
those kind of thoughts creep into your
mind and then of course wanting to
accept those challenges of going to new
england so yeah i mean
when you hear things like that yeah
you're not surprised they lost the big
question is
do you think what's the mike florio gut
tell you do you think the packers are
going to be able to run the ball on what
i call the psychos of the seattle
seahawks because that's what they got is
just a bunch of psychos who run around
big and want to knock your head off do
you think they can run the ball i think
they can but it's going to be you know
the old cliche run to set up the pass i
think we're going to see some pass to
set up the run you think that's going to
be that way
get them on their heels with some quick
strikes to devonta adams and then maybe
get the defense to refocus a bit and
open up some running i i you know what
mike i i you say that and i go i think i
agree with you because i would think
pete carroll being old school again old
school coaches traditionally if you look
around the nfl they're still in we're
going to stop the run type mode pete
carroll still like that yeah i think
you're probably right they'll probably
have the line of scrimmage stacked early
on they're not going to let aaron jones
go and yeah green bay might have to use
play action pass pass get them to back
off and then they can get back to the
runway how many times have we seen that
this year where devante adams is
targeted over and over again earlier
yeah you're right and then it adjusts
and the rest of the offense is open
green bays first 15 first 12 that's
where they win a lot of the games we've
talked about this year they jump out on
teams 14-0 17-3 and then they hold on
ugly after that but their starting of
their game between lefleur's game
planning and then of course roger's
ability to make plays when maybe the
game planning doesn't go the right way
and him coming out throwing darts all
over the place yeah they feed off of
that early and if they could get the
seahawks down early that would that will
be uh tough to overcome in in green bay
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports